dann kommen wir zum vierten und auf
keinen fall wichtigsten bewertungspunkte
dieses videos und zwar die größte der im
video gezeigte brüssel services kind
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich habe
gestern noch mit luca geschrieben und
luca meinte zu mir
morgen kommt man richtig krasser song
raus ein neuer track will muss sie auf
jeden fall rein ziehe ich dachte mir so
etwas wird sein vielleicht schon das
zweite 17 aus dass im jahr 2017 oder
robbie williams der zurückkommt ich
heiße ihr seht es da unten schon leute
stars natürlich nicht neid war der neue
song von katja und ich muss wirklich
sagen leute ich bin froh dass wir wieder
was passiert und youtube deutschland das
war irgendwie voll lange voll langweilig
oder aber das war jetzt wieder so eine
sache was ich dachte geil es passiert
mal wieder war es weißt du nicht zum
distrikt von zwei leuten wo eigentlich
auch niemand anders was damit zu tun hat
sondern wirklich so ein musikalisches
meisterwerk
und es ist wirklich gut was einfach so
raus gebracht wird an die massen jetzt
werden ein paar von euch vielleicht
denken bohr alter sg du machst es nur um
wieder klick sogar du verdammt der
bastard und mit bastard habt ihr auf
jeden fall recht aber tatsächlich habe
ich mich eben schon bisschen umgeschaut
das ist jetzt vier stunden nach seiner
veröffentlichung heute vier stunden es
sind nur vier stunden und es sind schon
gefühlt 30.000 videos online die auf den
von reagieren
wie machen die leute das was ich sagen
will auf jeden fall ich habe gesehen
dass videos gar nicht so doll ziehen die
bringen nicht so viele klicks aber ich
mache dass wir trotzdem weil ich so was
einfach liebe ich liebe es mir schräge
sachen reinzuziehen ich liebe es euch
die zeit mich darauf reagiere
und eigentlich liebes-aus bisschen
gemein zu einer leuten zu sein
aber das sage ich nicht öffentlich
deswegen heute wissen jetzt an dem punkt
in die verein starten werden wie werden
sie den auszügen anschaulich welche das
ganze ding abspielen wenn es auszüge
anschauen danach werde ich das video
bewährten anhand von vier kriterien und
zwar bild ton text und größe der im
video gezeigten brüste wobei die ersten
drei natürlich definitiv für mich die
wichtigsten kriterien sind dann werde
ich sagen was ich von dem song halte und
ich glaube ihm passen euch wird das
überraschend ganz normale situation
soweit vier damen mitte 40 halten gerade
eine tupperparty ab
dann passiert aber irgendwas mit diesen
älteren hausfrauen man weiß nicht was es
ist ja aber irgendwie kommen sie auf den
tripp das ist doch eine geile idee wäre
wenn eine von ihnen den pizzaboten würde
das ist mir jetzt persönlich mit meinen
kumpels so nicht passiert der erste
blick und der erste kontakt alter kraft
wollen den hans entertainment
ausgekommen
wie immer ist es wieder hier auch sehr
hilfreich sich diese situation in
welchen leben vorzustellen der welt vor
ihr seid pizzabote die letzte fahrt des
abends waren irgendwelche tanten nachts
um drei doch ne pizza margherita
bestellt haben dann geht da rein seit
dem gedanken scheinen bett gibt die
pizza und antwort euch die alte einfach
an
man denkt euch sol.de ja ich bin echt im
falschen film mal ganz davon abgesehen
dass ist wirklich hart hemmings
zwillingsbruder mit braunen haaren ist
was hier gerade abgeht katja für für den
pizzaboten das müsst ihr euch auf jeden
fall selbst anschaut
[Musik]
ich muss sagen die erste strophe war gar
nicht so schlecht denn eigentlich
wirklich so die den wald getroffen den
sie überbringen will aber die huk das
passt eben nicht so zum thema da würde
ich mir eher so candy shop nächsten so
gebiet vorstellen so der pizzabote hat
jetzt auch gedacht meine fresse wie
kommen jetzt aus der situation wieder
raus na gut dann fahre ich halt ein
bisschen mit
ich will nicht vom thema ablenken ich
weiß gerade und doggy style und das kann
ja eigentlich keinen sex haben wir so
aber hier ist der kollege aus dem
musikvideo und hier ist hans ich sag
nichts mehr dazu tut mir wirklich leid
da seht ihr wirklich den verzweifelten
pizzaboten der einfach nur noch nach
hause möchte und jetzt haben die die
wilden hausfrauen vom typ a wann treffen
noch männer dazu geholt die ihnen dabei
helfen den pizzaboten festzuhalten
[Musik]
das ist übrigens aus wieder verloren
zwillingsbruder von clemens alive also
nicht nämlich nicht immer den
der pizzabote hat es aus diesem horror
haus raus geschafft kommen wir zur
bewertung als aller erstes video geil
geil des videos richtig gut gemacht
schöne setting audio wie gesagt die
erste strophe finde ich gut die erste
strophe bringt auch so diesen weit über
das hat er jetzt wirklich denn das
bringt wirklich so diese stimmung rüber
so man denkt sich so ok alles klar gut
der wein kommt rüber und dann kommt
diese druck und die zerstören diese
stimme komplett audio ist nicht so toll
aber es ist auch eine youtube muss man
dazu sagen dann kommen wir zum text also
ich persönlich kann an dem text wirklich
überhaupt nichts aussetzen
hat sich jemand sehr lange hingesetzt
und ich glaube dann kommen wir zum
vierten und auf keinen fall wichtigsten
bewertungspunkte dieses videos und zwar
die größte der im video gezeigt brüssel
muss ich wirklich sagen sehr gut manche
würden jetzt sagen dass das einzige
merkmal nachdem katjas videos im
allgemeinen bewertet werden ich würde es
wahrscheinlich auch zu sagen aber kommen
wir zum fazit deute ich muss wirklich
sagen ich feiere den song
da kommt nicht so diese haas stimmung
rüber wie das bei bibi war es ist
musikalisch halt wirklich nicht toll
aber ich finde es einfach lust nicht ich
finde es schon krasse unterschied zu
baby baby hat mich halt echt um
mitgemacht weil es das war nicht lustig
bei babys weiter
schräg finde ich und deswegen werde ich
etwas sagen wollte wofür dieses video
20.000 des lecks bekommen wird und zwar
ich finde dokki ist der beste youtuber
song seit baba wagen